we're going live to the Pentagon that's
where the spokesman Patrick writer is
taking questions and speaking right now
on the origins of leaked documents that
have been made public a significant
amount of top secret information
including information on Ukraine's
military capabilities let's listen in
what we can say about any of the
documents themselves and while we
certainly understand the media's
interest in asking questions about the
contents of these documents I will
highlight that as a matter of
long-standing policy
just because classified information may
be posted online or elsewhere does not
mean it has been Declassified by a
classification Authority
and those of you who have been covering
the Pentagon for a long time know that
we're just not going to discuss or
confirm classified information due to
the potential impact on National
Security as well as the Safety and
Security of our personnel and those of
our allies and our partners and for that
reason we will continue to encourage
those of you who are reporting this
story to take these ladder factors into
account
and to consider the potential
consequences of posting potentially
sensitive documents or information
online or elsewhere
separately secretary Austin hosted
Latvia's minister of defense inaro
mernisse today at the Pentagon the
leaders discussed the strength of the
U.S lot via defense relationship and
ongoing efforts to support Ukraine they
also discussed shared security interests
in Europe including NATO's deterrence
and defense posture ahead of the July
NATO Summit in Vilnius readout will be
available later today
on Europe for a moment next week
secretary Austin will travel to Sweden
to meet with his counterpart to discuss
security related topics shared by our
two Nations
from there he'll travel to Germany where
he and chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff General milley will host an
in-person meeting on April 21 of the
Ukraine defense contact group at
Ramstein Air Base this will be the 11th
meeting of the udcg since this vital
form was established by secretary Austin
one year ago
the secretary and general Millie will
join Ministers of defense and Senior
military officials from nearly 50
Nations around the world to discuss the
ongoing crisis in Ukraine and to
continue our close coordination on
providing the Ukrainian people with the
means necessary to protect themselves
against Russia's unprovoked and illegal
aggression and as we've highlighted
before the contact group has been
instrumental in identifying
synchronizing and ensuring delivery of
the military capabilities the ukrainians
need to defend their Homeland
and on a semi-related note at the end of
this month the Arkansas Army National
Guard's 39th infantry Brigade combat
team will replace the New York Army
National Guard's 27th infantry Brigade
combat team and assumed command of the
joint multinational training group
Ukraine at grafenwear training area in
Germany the 27th infantry Brigade combat
team took charge of the jmtgu during a
transfer Authority ceremony in August of
2022 becoming the first and only unit in
the jmtgu's eight-year history to assume
the unit mission for a second time we
look forward to the arrival of the 39th
and the continuation of the important
work to provide Ukraine what it needs in
terms of training to defend itself and
with that I'll be happy to go to your
questions we'll go ahead and start with
AP to our cup
uh thank you General Ryder so can you
confirm that everyone Airman First Class
Jack Tashara a member of the
Massachusetts Air National Guard is a
person of interest in this leaked
documents case I have several other
questions sure so first of all as I
mentioned there is an ongoing criminal
investigation and so anything related to
that I'm going to need to refer you to
the the doj or the FBI can you speak at
all to if anyone in the Department of
Defense has reached out to this Airman
do you know where he is there are
reports that law enforcement is closing
in on this airman's location
um so has anyone been able to reach out
to him again Tara I appreciate the
question but again given that this is an
ongoing investigation I'm not going to
be able to talk about the investigation
or any potential doj actions so I'd
refer you to them okay in the days after
the leaks came to light what steps has
DOD taken to reduce the number of people
who have access to not only these
classified briefings but the classified
material in general sure so we continue
to review a variety of factors as it
relates to safeguarding classified
materials this includes examining and
updating distribution lists assessing
how and where intelligence products are
shared in a variety of other steps I
would say though that it is it is
important to understand
that we do have stringent guidelines in
place for safeguarding classified and
sensitive information this was a
deliberate criminal act a violation of
those guidelines uh and so again I think
that's important to understand now we
will continue to do everything we can to
ensure that that people who have a need
to know uh when it comes to this kind of
information have access to that
um we're always going to learn from
every situation
um but again
um this is something that we'll continue
to look at but you are taking steps so
that is the Pentagon spokesman Patrick
Ryder he's taking questions from
reporters on the origins of leaked
documents that made public a significant
amount of top secret information
including information on Ukraine's
military capabilities and they were
classified documents from the Department
of Defense that were found online let's
bring in shiha britansi he's joining us
from Washington DC so
um I mean tell us more of what the
spokesman just have to say and I suppose
Pentagon officials are working around
the clock to really understand the scope
and scale of these leaks
well I think the Press reports that he
was he was referring to there he said he
was aware of the press reports but he
wasn't going to be drawn on them and he
referred any questions to the Department
of Justice because it's the FBI and the
doj who are now investigating the source
of these leaks but now for but now it's
been widely reported in the New York
Times Washington Post Wall Street
Journal that the the main suspect is a
21 year old member of the intelligence
wing of the Massachusetts Air National
Guard in fact just in the last few
minutes the New York Times is reporting
FBI agents have now are now searching
his home in Massachusetts and we had
been told to expect an arrest perhaps on
Thursday off of this of the Suspects
it appears from from all the reporting
that's been done that he began posting
all this information online in a chat
room popular with video Gamers over the
course of several months and there's
been much speculation about the
motivation as a you know is there some
political intent is this about
whistleblowing from all the reporting
that we're seeing it appears that this
is simply about impressing the others in
the chat room of his um importance and
trying to trying to get them in fact he
was he was rather disappointed at first
because they weren't really the other
members of the chat room who were just
like young Gamers uh but but in an
international group of young Gamers
weren't really paying enough attention
and that initially he was apparently
transcribing these these secret reports
or these classified reports but but in
order to get to make more have more of
an impact he started photographing these
documents or at least apparently and as
far as we can see from the photographs
and you know they're folds in them and
so on you know he would he would fold
these documents out he take photographs
take photographs off these documents to
try and make more of an impact to Simply
to Impress his fell his fellow Gamers I
think there isn't that much surprise
that that a suspect was narrowed down
because they're identifying features in
the photographs we know who the chat the
chat room where the chat room uh is and
who and who was the leader of that group
so I don't think there's that much
surprise that actually that the FBI
apparently has has decided that um they
have a suspect
so shihab how is the U.S though trying
to sort of contain the Fallout from from
what's came out in these leagues
it was interesting President Biden was
asked about this in Ireland whether he
was concerned and he was really
downplaying and saying no no he's you
know he doesn't feel that the you know
any that he wasn't too concerned about
the leaks having said that on Wednesday
we were told that Secretary of State
blinken and defense secretary Austin
were making calls to various allies to
try and reassure them because not only
do these leaks show that the US is
spying as you might expect on Russia and
Iran uh possibly China well you know and
so on but also on on a lot of allies
Egypt Israel South Korea and of course
Ukraine itself to be honest I don't
think there's that much surprise that
the U.S is is spying on all these
countries we knew that anyway from the
Wikileaks
documents that we got from Edward
Snowden you know 10 years ago or 13
years ago which showed it wide scale
surveillance of world leaders you know
bugging Angela merkel's phone and so on
so I don't think there's that much
surprise but I think there's a there
will be that embarrassment and it it
shows in fact you know the ukrainians
say well you know we don't really share
that much information with the Americans
anyway because we don't trust them to
keep their secrets okay thank you she
have retancy reporting from Washington
D.C